e
e e
okay we're going to begin the notice
executive session of the house election
law committee um I'm going to make a
motion to reconsider cacr 22 is there a
second I second the motion
all in favor uh call the vote all in
favor say I I all oppos say no the eyes
have it thank
you we will stand in recess for two
minutes
for
e e
okay we're uh 2020 now um motion to
reconsider uh cacr 22 carried when the
executive session opened we are now on
we're now back on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on cacr 22 um
is there any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate hearing none the clerk will
call the role on the motion of any
expedient to legislate for cacr 22 uh
Representative quae
no point order please we're in the
voting mode okay Representative
inberg no representative Burnham
no Representative warry no
representative wood no representative
Osborne no Representative kutab no
representative Alexander no
representative
Lan I'm sorry I I was not aware of
voting on this so um I don't know I
don't know what to do I didn't have a
chance to respond assume not
voting it's okay we're not going to get
we're not going to get to 10 anyway
so nobody said what cacr 22 relates to
cacr 22 is putting the the uh first and
Nation primary into the state
constitution uh and we're reconsidering
it we the motion to reconsider is
already
carried ago and now we're voting again
on itl
the motion to reconsider carried when we
reached a majority we are now
reconsidering the vote we we are now
voting on the motion of any spe to
legisl in cacr 22 we in the vo I believe
that there may be some confusion amongst
the Democratic members who showed up a
few minutes late because there was a
motion that happened before you showed
up so the motion to reconsider had was a
Voice vote unanimously 14 to0 before the
entire committee got here correct
because you need a majority to open
executive
session I understand um we can continue
the vote
okay 22
22 do you want to
vote
um I want to know how I object to the
Parliamentary proceeding that was put in
place we all came over here right after
the session i w walk immediately from my
seat and walk directly here I understand
you could follow your objection with the
clerk and the speaker but we are in the
voting mode okay so the motion for C CA
cr22 22 is inex we are reconsidering the
motion to reconsider has passed we are
now on the vote we are now back on the
original motion which was inexpedient to
legislate on cacr
22 I understand we are in the voting
mode um I will
vote the uh cacr 22 would put in the
Constitution that we have to be the
first in the nation correct that I'm
voting against it so you vote you voting
for the
motion the motion that is is then for
itl correct correct okay so you're
voting yes correct okay eventually yes
yes there we go representative Ward yes
representative
hamr
yes representative Hamlet no
representative
Mirad I the motion is inexpedient to
legislate so if you are against the
legislation you would vote Yes if you
are for the legislation you would vote
no so yes on the no uh representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes yes
representative Grill no representative
Howard um yes representative rter
yes that is I did not vote chair sorry
the chair votes no and I believe
representative pudm O'Brien was just to
representative pom O'Brien I'm sorry no
okay would any Miss would any member
wish to change their vote I would okay
representative Hamlet's going to change
from a no to a yes
would any other member wish to change
their
vote okay with that the motion of
inexpedient to legislate fails on a vote
of n uh 11 to9 um I will now make a
motion of ought to pass is there a
second I second kab seconds is there any
discussion on the bill yes there is
discussion on the bill representative
Brennan has a question yes thank you uh
can you go through how it was 11 to9
I thought it was 101 I voted uh
no thank you in support of the
cacr yeah
um is there any other discussion on the
motion of ought to pass yes represent
Lane yes I
um I will file a motion on how this has
hand been handled um it also we have
worked so hard for two years to have a
really great
bipartisan relationship ship and in one
vote you've managed I think to really
destroy that how can we
trust
that I'm just y i I understand
personally I'm personally offended but
also just as a group that's just not how
we have operated for two years I I
understand L I figured you and I would
speak after this and I will explain to
you my rationale behind it um it is
within the rules it was a notice
executive session I said cacr 22 from
the from the well it is per the rules I
believe it's Rule 13 um the the
executive session requires a majority
present and voting we waited until that
point and all we did was call for the
motion to reconsider um anyways is there
any other discussion on the motion of
ought to
pass yes represent representative Grill
maybe I'm getting DJ Vu but I think we
passed a cacr already this session uh we
did not pass a cacr already on this one
yet no I thought that was representative
Howard yeah so uh to to representative
Grill's Point uh one of the things that
we have discussed was statutory changes
that would give the Secretary of State
more flexibility as to how they could
set the primary date the problem in what
we've uh been discussing is yes I think
everybody in this room supports the
first in the nation presidential primary
that's not a question what the debate is
and what the situation of putting the uh
date in the constitution is is that it
creates a completely rigid system that
does not create uh any flexibility in
how we can set the date so it kind of
leaves us in a situation where we could
be usurped uh and it would make it more
difficult for us to change when we can
actually hold our primary thank you
further discussion on the cacr
representative Lane as I recall when we
discussed this
before uh if by by Chance the uh cacr
does not
pass then it puts the state in a very
awkward position of trying to continue
to be first in the nation so we would be
shooting ourselves in the foot if that's
what we wanted to do I understand
representative Brennan thank you in the
past there has been bipartisan support
for our first in the nation primary and
and
bipartisan support
against a constitutional amendment for
something that is controlled by the
Secretary of
State to have this bill come up and be
acting in the way that this committee is
acting
today is very strange to
me why we would want to put our voters
and our state in this position to take a
vote on a constitutional amendment that
very well could
fail and where does that leave the state
in defending our first in the nation
primary not one of us knows the outcome
of a vote on a constitutional amendment
for first in the nation primary it is a
very high bar to get a constitu
Amendment passed by voters who may not
feel as strongly as some of us feel
about the value in defending our first
and the nation
primary is this really a
risk that this committee wants to take
do you want to risk the losing the first
in the nation primary because that's
entirely possible if this were were to
go to the
voters you do not know the outcome of
this how much do you value our first in
the nation
primary are you willing to take this
risk I think in principle many of us
feel strongly in support of our first
the nation primary and do not want to
take that risk of losing it by a small
margin because that's all that it would
take to lose it a small margin to lose
it a huge High bar to secure the first
of the nation Primary in our
constitution our state law has been
doing just fine in defending our first
the nation primary our secretary of
state has
emphatically supported our first the
nation primary even when Party politics
have been at play from both parties
over the years New Hampshire has
defended our first than Nation primary
simply by following our state law to put
this in our constitution or to attempt
to put it in our constitution actually
does more harm to the history and the
tradition and the maintenance of our
first the nation
primary I'm very
concerned representative katad I think
it is a very important topic and I think
it should absolutely be left to the
voters to decide on and I think it is
bipartisan I mean it it did pass on the
other side of the wall unanimously so I
think that there's a lot of support for
this I think a lot of people want to see
us first in the nation a lot of
businesses really depend on our first in
the nation for renting out hotel rooms
and other things you know for their
economical survival really so I think
it's a really important thing that we
support this thank you
excuse me representative
qualey I don't consider
putting a motion to the voters to be a
risk because I trust that the voters
will make the right decision
collectively in fact I think the will of
the voters will be by definition the
right decision thank
you any other member wish to comment who
hasn't commented yet representative
Warden just one comment since the
legislation for the primary came out of
Portsmith I feel I should say something
uh uh I'm not sure representative Spain
would go along with this I do have a
question let's say this passes is an
inin in the Constitution what do the
other 49 states
care does it have any Authority with
anybody it's a great philosophical
question yeah repes uh I am going to
come back I'm not ignoring represent you
know that I have to let other people who
spoke not yet spoke and speak and then I
come back to you I'm asking for a caucus
I'm you're asking for a caucus I will
allow a caucus uh how long do you need
representative
Lane we can be here back in an hour it's
fine um how how about we give you 10 a
charactering moment I understand uh
12:25 good for you representative
Lane
okay
e
e e
okay uh 111
1225 uh we are still on discussion of
the motion of ought to pass is there any
further discussion on the motion of
ought to
pass yes representative Brennan just a
a inquiry uh
um if the if ought to pass passes and it
goes to the house floor what is the uh
threshold for passing a cacr on the
house floor a cacr is a three-fifth vote
of the those members present and voting
and it has to be a roll call vote just
to correct that it's not president
voting entire caucus I apoc asize and a
quick followup what is the threshold for
voters If This Were to go to the voters
what is the
threshold the amount of Voters that need
to vote in favor I understand the
question the uh threshold to pass a
constitutional amendment in the state of
New Hampshire requires 66% of the voters
voting thank you and one more follow up
if I may
um who is going to be responsible for
the uh
financial burden of campaigning to pass
a cacr which tends to be an expensive
Endeavor to reach as many voters as
possible to reach that
threshold uh to encourage the passage of
aacr who who is financially responsible
for that it's a great question for the
body would anyone like to answer it okay
uh any other members wish to comment on
the motion of ought to pass on cacr 22
hearing none the clerk will call the
role representative quae yes
representative P O'Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kab yes representative
Alexander yes uh representative Lane no
representative Ward no representative HR
no representative Hamlet no
representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no Representative
rter
no uh chairman Barry chair votes yes
with that the motion of about to pass
fails the bill be reported out without
recommendation uh I will take the a pass
report excuse me I'm Miss yes
representative Lane how how is it going
to be passed with no representation we
we reconsidered it we voted not to ought
to pass it so now we have to do
something else so we voted for we voted
against itl correct to reconsider we
voted to reconsider we voted against the
mo the the bill had originally been
voted 20 to Z inexpedient to legislate
correct correct so when we did the
reconsideration it went back to the the
prevailing motion which was inexpedient
to legislate we voted down in
inexpedient to legislate down we just
voted did not vote up ought to pass so
it is now without recommendation EXC
motion oh there's a new motion okay yes
I would like to motion interim study
okay there's a motion from interim study
is there a
second second is there any discussion on
the motion of interim study yeah I'll
I'll speak to my motion uh so this is
something where putting the presidential
primary into the Constitution I think
needs to be looked at a little bit more
in depth this is something where usually
we've approached this from a statutory
uh framework and that's worked out very
well our secretary of state has been
able to keep our presidential primary
for the last 100 years it's something
where we are able to update it and
maintain uh the presidential primary
requirements as necessary and easily
through the uh statutory means because
we don't need to go back to the voters
every single time we want to make a
change we don't necessarily know what
the impact of putting this in the
constitution is going to be are other
states going to listen to the New
Hampshire Constitution do we have
jurisdiction over them I think not and
these are questions that I think need to
be answered before we go and actually
vote on adding this into the
Constitution I think that we all support
the presidential uh primary and the
first in the nation I do I I voted for
the statutory changes but this is
something where we're not necessarily
talking about the first in the nation
primary when we're talking about the
issues with the legislation the
potential issues and that's why I think
that we need to study this a bit further
thank you is there any further
discussion on the motion of in uh EXC me
intrum study excuse me uh hearing none
the clerk will call the role on the
motion of any interim
study qua no representative pom O'Brien
no Representative inberg no
representative Burnham no representative
wary no representative wood no
representative
Osborne no Representative cutab no no
representative Alexander no
representative Wayan yes representative
Ward representative HR yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennon yes
representative gr yes representative
Howard yes representative Raptor yes uh
chairman Barry chair chair votes no with
that the motion of interim study uh
fails on a vote of 10 to 10 any other
motions anyone like to make
okay now we now the bill will be
reported out without recommendation um
representative Lane who would you like
to take the interim study
report representative Howard will be
respons for the interm study report
excellent um and I'll take the OTP okay
now on to hopefully nicer things um
we're going to close the executive
session on cacr 22 open the executive
session on Senate Bill 534 relative to
campaign finance representative Lane is
recognized for a
motion um I I move to ought to pass all
right I will second the motion of ought
to pass represent Lane do you have an
amendment do you want to pass your am oh
yes um I'm
sorry uh I can't remember the number uh
I have it it's 1582 I think but I'm not
sure let me trust but verify
yeah what was it representative Lane
15 I think it's 1582 but I don't
have uh I'm sorry I thought we'd have C
no it's okay
okay I don't know is
that okay thank you okay representative
Lane moves Amendment 202 24-1 1856 h i
will second the amendment is there any
discussion on the
amendment I
will okay
um I just I do want to thank the
subcommittee and the committee for
working so hard on the bill and for
being patient and uh chiming in it's
been a
slog so thank you very much I I UT that
and I appreciate the thanks
representative Lane but the reality is
you carried most of the work on this um
so you actually do deserve most of the
thanks um it was a team effort but you
did most of the work representative
quing yes I just want to reinforce what
you just said about representative Lane
really doing the heavy lifting on it and
I do appre appreciate the fact we were
able to work on it
cooperatively meeting with the Senate is
never fun um all right uh it's not a
dispositive motion so we can pass it
with a Voice vote so all in favor of
adopting Amendment 15
1856 H to house bill Senate bill um good
Lord Senate Bill 534 say I I all opposed
say no the I have it on a vote of 20 to
zero uh we are now uh representative
Lane is now recognized for a new motion
I make a motion for ought to pass as
amended representative lay moves ought
to pass as amended I second is there any
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill
534 hearing none the clerk will call the
role representative qua yes
representative pom o Brian yes
representative inberg yes representative
Burnham yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes representative kutab yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes uh
representative Lane you've already done
all the work on this bill would you like
the report or would you like somebody
else to handle the report all right hand
Report with that this will be the last
time we meet we have no more bills uh is
have a fiscal no it can go on the
consent calendar um so yes we will go on
uh any objection to consent calendar
hearing none I'll go on the consent
calendar thank you guys so much and I
imagine I'll have some people who want
to talk to me so see you guys
there e